when you think of summer grilling you
usually think of savory foods
but you can also make really great
desserts right on the grill we're gonna
focus on two of the most popular grilled
desserts a cobbler and a crumble
sure you can make these in the oven but
let's talk about why you should be
grilling your desserts
listen it's summertime it's hot you
don't want to make your kitchen even
hotter by turning that oven on if you're
having a summer barbecue you don't want
to be going back and forth inside
outside get outside hang out with your
friends hang out with your family get
grilling
first up we're going to show you how to
make a versatile fruity filling that you
can use with a bunch of desserts the
great thing about these recipes is that
the filling's the same
your main components are going to be
sugar a binder
salt vanilla acid and fruit first
combine sugar
next up for our binder we tested flour
cornstarch and tapioca
turns out they all had really similar
results the recipe already calls for
flour it works just as well next add a
bit of salt it helps enhance the flavor
of all the other ingredients in baked
goods
then you're ready to add your acid in
our case we're using lemon juice and
zest next add your vanilla place your
vanilla bean on a cutting board you're
going to use a parry knife to slowly
gently split it in half
and then take one half of the pod
and scrape all the seeds that's the
stuff you're gonna save
you could use an extract but if you
spring for the real deal you'll get an
extra punch of flavor then you're ready
to add your fruit for this filling
you'll need 8 cups of any fruit you
could do a classic strawberry rhubarb
mixed berries or really anything that's
in season we're going with blueberries
and peaches you can also use frozen
fruit you'll get a pretty similar result
but why not take advantage of summer
produce if you want to take it up a
notch you can also grill your fruit
it does take some extra time so you can
totally skip this step but it will add
some extra flavor
now it's really simple you're just going
to give it a quick stir you want to make
sure the fruit is fully covered with the
sugar mixture now that that's ready
transfer your filling into your dish or
cookware for your cookware you could use
stainless steel metal or cast iron you
just want to make sure that whatever you
use it's grill friendly for this recipe
we're using a standard 10 inch cast iron
skillet but you could adapt this for
whatever cookware you have at home add
your filling to the cookware you want to
make sure there's a little extra room on
top so that the fruit doesn't bubble
over and overflow
now we're going to set that aside while
we prep our topping it's totally fine to
sit in the fridge for a few hours or up
to overnight the easiest topping to
round off this dessert is a crumble
for the crumble you're going to use
flour
sugar oats butter
salt and spices
you could also make a crisp by just
taking out the oats they're both pretty
similar so it's just up to you with
which one you prefer this one's super
foolproof first you mix your dry
ingredients until fully incorporated
then using your hands break the butter
up into pea sized pieces they can be a
little uneven don't worry about it you
could use a pastry cutter to cut up the
butter if you had one but we like the
rustic look you get from breaking it up
with your hands now that you have your
topping just spread it in an even layer
all over the fruit
it kind of looks like a lot but remember
there's eight cups of fruit in there you
want to make sure you have enough
topping to balance all that fruit to
cook or crumble you want to preheat the
grill to 350. you're going to cook it
over indirect heat with the lid closed
for about an hour and 30 minutes we'd
suggest checking your crumble after
about an hour
grilling isn't an exact science and
grills can be really finicky you don't
want this to burn
some people might think it's done at
this point but if you see any underbaked
flour or these really light golden parts
that means it's not ready
when it's finished it should look like
this you're looking for a golden brown
gorgeous topping and the fruity filling
to be bubbling and oozing through and
that's your crumble
for something a little more involved
kick it up a notch and try a cobbler a
lot of people top their cobbler with pie
batter for something that's a total
showstopper we're going to show you how
to make a biscuit topping for the
biscuits you'll need flour milk or cream
butter salt sugar baking powder and a
little extra sugar to sprinkle on top
first add all your dry ingredients and
give that a good whisk until they're
well combined
now we're gonna add our butter for your
butter you can totally cube it but pro
tip try grating it it's a little extra
effort but it makes it easier to combine
the butter evenly once that's set add
your milk or cream
for this recipe we tested milk heavy
cream and buttermilk they all work great
but we're going with buttermilk because
we love the tanginess it added you'll
know your dough is ready when it's got
this shaggy texture
now turn your dough out onto a floured
surface and flatten it into a rectangle
then start rolling it out for this
you're going to want to do the book end
trick take your rolling pin and roll
your rectangle out until it's a little
bigger
then
gently fold it in half roll it out again
you're gonna do this four or five times
you don't need to do more than that this
process builds the layers of butter
resulting in a super flaky tender
biscuit
now that your dough's all rolled out
it's time to cut out your biscuits you
want to take your pastry or cookie
cutter and dip that right in a bowl of
flour that'll keep it from sticking to
the dough when you're cutting out your
biscuits make sure you press straight
down without twisting your cutter back
and forth that way you'll get a clean
cut twisting it back and forth is going
to crimp the edges and your biscuits
won't be as tall and fluffy place the
biscuits on top of your fruit filling
making sure that they're all touching
lastly brush the biscuits with a little
more buttermilk milk or egg wash to give
them a nice sheen
then top them with a little bit of sugar
we're going to use raw sugar for some
extra texture but you can totally use
white sugar too it's important to keep
this in the fridge until you're ready to
grill so that the butter in your
biscuits doesn't melt resulting in a
soggy mess same as the crumble preheat
your grill to 350 degrees again you're
going to do this over indirect heat
we're going to grill this for an hour
and 15 minutes with the lid closed you
want to start checking your cobbler
early if it's starting to get too brown
just tent it with tin foil for the
remaining time when your cobbler is done
the biscuit should be golden brown on
top and the filling should be bubbly and
oozing
and that's it i know you want to eat
this right away but you really want to
let it rest for at least 30 minutes so
that the filling can set
this is a great base recipe to
experiment with and they're really
delicious i think that's the thing like
these are so good whether it's a crumble
or a cobbler feel free to top it off
with some fan favorites like ice cream
or whipped cream we love them both you
can't go wrong with a crumble or cobbler
you really can't happy grilling
vanilla extract vanilla vanilla
am i saying all right vanilla
vanilla
vanilla do ice
vanilla
vanilla
vanilla
vanilla okay it doesn't matter it's fine